Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
ARE YOU MARRIED?
NO, SIR.
I LIKE LONG ROMANTIC WALKS
TO THE BANK.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHOO-HOO!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
BUT I HAVE A CAVEAT.
BUT I'M NOT GONNA TELL YOU
WHAT THE CAVEAT IS
UNTIL YOU GIVE ME
AN ANSWER.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
SHE'S GIVING YOU
A JANET JACKSON DEAL
'CAUSE SHE WANTS CONTROL.
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR
THEY'LL WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
YOU DON'T WANT
TO GO OUT ON THIS.
I'M GONNA STEP OUT.
AND TONIGHT, THE BIGGEST DEAL
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY
TO DATE IS MADE.
I'LL GIVE YOU $2.5 MILLION
FOR 10%.
WOW.
Herjavec: WOW.
THIS IS THE BEST OFFER
KEVIN'S EVER MADE TO SOMEBODY.
ARE YOU GONNA TAKE MY DEAL
OR NOT?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
MY NAME IS STEPHEN HERSH, AND
I'M FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
SHOOT IT, SHOOT IT, SHOOT IT!
I LIVE WITH MY TWO KIDS,
AVY AND LEAH.
MY KIDS ARE AWESOME.
THEY MEAN EVERYTHING TO ME.
GROWING UP, I WATCHED MY FATHER
START AND RUN A HANDBAG COMPANY.
HE PUT EVERY PENNY HE HAD INTO
IT, AND HE TOOK A VERY BIG RISK.
AND HE DID IT.
HE BROKE OPEN ALL OF THE MAJOR
DEPARTMENT STORES,
AND HIS BUSINESS TOOK OFF
VERY QUICKLY AFTER THAT.
EVENTUALLY, MY FATHER AND
HIS PARTNER SOLD THEIR COMPANY
FOR A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
I DIDN'T GET ANY OF THE PROFITS,
AND I'M TOTALLY FINE WITH THAT.
I DON'T FEEL THAT I'M ENTITLED
TO GET SOMETHING
THAT I DIDN'T EARN.
NOW MY DAD AND I
HAVE STARTED A NEW COMPANY
IN A SIMILAR INDUSTRY.
I GOT THOSE DESIGNS.
I'M LOOKING AT IT RIGHT NOW.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS COMPANY,
WE BOUGHT A TON OF INVENTORY,
HE HIRED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE HADN'T EVEN SOLD ONE BAG YET,
AND WE WERE SPENDING
ALL THIS MONEY.
I HAD TO STOP MANUFACTURING
MY PRODUCT TEMPORARILY.
MOST OF WHAT I'M DOING NOW
IS PLANNING FOR A RELAUNCH
OF MY COMPANY.
I'VE LEARNED FROM MY MISTAKES,
AND IT'S TIME TO ASK FOR HELP.
A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE RIGHT SHARK
CAN BRING MY BUSINESS BACK,
AND IT CAN BE JUST AS SUCCESSFUL
AS MY DAD'S BUSINESS WAS BEFORE.
HI. I'M STEPHEN HERSH,
AND I'M FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
MY COMPANY IS BIAGGI,
AND I'M SEEKING
AN INVESTMENT OF $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 30%
OF MY COMPANY.
WHETHER WE LIVE IN A HOUSE,
A CONDO, OR AN APARTMENT,
IT ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE
WE HAVE SO MUCH STUFF
AND NOT ENOUGH SPACE
TO STORE IT IN.
VERY FEW THINGS EAT UP
MORE OF OUR LIVING SPACE
THAN OUR LUGGAGE.
BIAGGI LUGGAGE
IS YOUR STORAGE SOLUTION.
ALL BIAGGI LUGGAGE FOLDS FLAT.
OUR FOLDABLE SUITCASES
USE HINGE-LOCK TECHNOLOGY...
...WHICH KEEPS THESE BAGS STURDY
WHILE IN USE
AND EASY TO STORE
UNDER A BED OR ON A SHELF.
OUR SUPER LIGHTWEIGHT ZIPSAK
IS A SMALL POUCH
THAT AMAZINGLY TRANSFORMS
INTO THIS FULLY FEATURED
FOUR-WHEELED SPINNER.
IN THIS STANDARD PIECE
OF BEDROOM FURNITURE,
I'VE STORED 11 PIECES
OF LUGGAGE.
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE SPACE
THAT THIS LUGGAGE WOULD TAKE UP
IN YOUR HOME.
OUR LUGGAGE IS THE LUGGAGE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE
WHEN YOU'RE TRAVELING
AND ALSO WHEN YOU'RE NOT.
SO, WHICH ONE OF YOU
CAN WE WELCOME TO THE FOLD?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, PROVE TO ME PEOPLE CARE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
YES. SO, WE'VE HAD $2.5 MILLION
OF SALES IN TWO YEARS.
WOW.
SO, THE FIRST YEAR
WAS A FULL YEAR OF SELLING.
THIS YEAR,
WE SOLD FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND THEN, BASICALLY,
WE HIT PAUSE ON MANUFACTURING
BECAUSE WE DID LEARN
SOME THINGS,
AND WE DECIDED
THAT INSTEAD OF --
SO, WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
WHAT WE LEARNED WAS
THAT CONSUMER EDUCATION
IS THE CHALLENGE
WITH THIS PRODUCT.
WE BOUGHT A TON OF INVENTORY
STRAIGHT OFF THE BAT.
AND THAT WAS DEFINITELY
A MISTAKE.
WHEN YOU HIT THE ROADBLOCK,
YOU HAD TO LIQUIDATE
A LOT OF YOUR INVENTORY.
CORRECT.
SO, HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY
DO YOU HAVE IN THIS?
WE INVESTED $3.5 MILLION
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
WOW!
$3.5 MILLION?!
WE DIDN'T LOSE $3.5 MILLION, BUT
WE INVESTED THAT OFF THE BAT.
WHO IS "WE"?
ME AND MY FAMILY
AND OUR LONG-TIME PARTNER
FROM THE LAST BUSINESS
THAT WE WERE IN.
WHAT WAS THE LAST BUSINESS?
THE LAST BUSINESS
WAS A HANDBAG BUSINESS.
AND WAS THE NAME
OF THE HANDBAG BUSINESS?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT ONE?
THE NAME OF THE HANDBAG BUSINESS
IS ROSETTI.
WE SOLD IT FOR $162 MILLION.
WOW.
GOOD FOR YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Hersh:
IT WASN'T ME THAT DID IT.
DID YOU GET
ANY OF THE $162 MILLION?
NO, NO, NO.
OH!
I'M HUNGRY TO GET IT WITH THIS.
Herjavec:
SO, YOU WORKED THERE,
BUT YOU WEREN'T AN OWNER
OF ROSETTI?
NO, MY FATHER WAS THE OWNER
OF ROSETTI, HIM AND --
HE DIDN'T THROW YOU A BONE?
YOU KNOW WHAT? MY FATHER DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN DOING THAT.
WHAT CAN I SAY?
I LOVE HIM!
Greiner: NEITHER DO YOU.
I LOVE THE GUY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HOW MUCH DOES
THE PINK BAG COST,
AND WHAT
DO YOU MAKE IT FOR?
OKAY, $62 TO LAND IT
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT.
John: THAT'S A LOT.
BUT GO AHEAD.
AND WHAT
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
YEAH. SO, WE SELL IT
WHOLESALE FOR $124.
MM-HMM.
AND IT RETAILS FOR $269.
THAT'S FOR THE LARGEST SIZE.
AND WHO
ARE YOU SELLING TO?
John: RIGHT.
SO, THIS WAS THE BLESSING
AND THE CURSE WITH BIAGGI.
SO, WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED BIAGGI,
BEFORE WE EVEN BROUGHT A PIECE
OF LUGGAGE INTO THIS COUNTRY,
WE GOT AN ORDER FROM
A LARGER DEPARTMENT STORE
TO PUT US INTO 100 STORES
WITH 2 OF OUR LINES.
IT WAS -- WE WERE REALLY
EXCITED, OBVIOUSLY.
AND --
SO AM I.
THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
YEAH. THERE WAS A MAJOR ISSUE
THAT HAD TO BE FIGURED OUT,
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY
TALKING TO YOU.
BUT CONSUMER EDUCATION
ON THE FLOOR.
SO, EVEN THE SALES PEOPLE
DIDN'T KNOW
THAT IT COLLAPSED, RIGHT?
I WENT INTO ONE STORE.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
WE HAVE --
BUT WAIT.
IT GETS WORSE.
THIS IS THE STORAGE BAG.
WHEN YOU FOLD THIS LUGGAGE,
IT COMES IN A STORAGE BAG
LIKE THIS.
SO, I GO TO ONE STORE, AND ALL
I SEE ON THE FLOOR ARE THESE.
Greiner: OH, NO.
THAT'S IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S IT.
John: ABSOLUTELY.
YOU'RE LUCKY THEY EVEN
BROUGHT IT OUT OF THE BACK.
Cuban: STEPHEN, I LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE HONEST
AND JUST STRAIGHT UP
TO THE POINT, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
BUT WHAT
I'M REALLY HEARING IS,
NOW YOU'RE JUST IN THE LUGGAGE
GAME WITH ONE EXTRA FEATURE.
IT IS WHAT IT IS,
BUT IT'S NOT A BUSINESS
I WANT TO BE IN.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, I ACCEPT THAT.
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO ME ANYWAYS.
Herjavec: STEPHEN --
I APPRECIATE IT.
FUNDAMENTALLY, HERE'S
WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY.
"I HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT THE CONSUMER
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND."
THAT'S A BIG CHALLENGE.
AND THERE IS A LOT
OF COMPETITION.
I DON'T SEE IT.
I'M OUT.
TOTALLY ACCEPT THAT, ROBERT,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
LISTENING TO ME.
SO, STEPHEN,
THIS IS A TOUGH BUSINESS.
IT REQUIRES
THE DEMONSTRATION,
EITHER ONLINE OR ON TELEVISION
OR AN INFOMERCIAL.
BUT, FOR ME, I'M OUT.
FAIR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
John: I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE STRATEGY.
UNLESS YOU HAVE
YOUR OWN TYPE OF STORE,
IT'S REALLY THE JCPENNEYs
AND THE DILLARDs
AND THE BURLINGTONs.
THEY HAVE HUNDREDS
OF FEETS OF LUGGAGE,
AND IT'S VERY HARD
TO DIFFERENTIATE.
BUT I ACTUALLY JUST DID A DEAL
WITH HSN FOR LUGGAGE.
SO, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $500,000
FOR...YEAH, FOR 33%.
THAT'S A TERRIFIC OFFER, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT, DAMON,
BUT I WOULD DEFINITELY
WANT TO --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
THE OFFER NOW OR NOT?
A-ARE YOU GIVING ME AN ULTIMATUM
OF I HAVE TO TAKE IT NOW OR NOT,
ON THE SPOT?
I'M NOT GIVING YOU
AN ULTIMATUM.
I'LL ONLY GIVE YOU
20 SECONDS
'CAUSE I GOT A DEADLY SHARKETTE
THAT'S BEING QUIET.
BUT YOU HAVE 20 SECONDS.
AND SHE'S SWIMMING IN THE WATER
TOWARDS YOU.
20 SECOND, LORI.
COME ON. 20 SECONDS.
YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
IN THE LUGGAGE BUSINESS.
I HAVE SOLD HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PIECES
OF MY WEEKENDER BAG
ON QVC.
10 SECONDS.
IT WAS UNIQUE.
IT HAD A CLEVER,
DIFFERENT FUNCTION.
SO, YOUR BAGS ARE
APPEALING TO ME
BECAUSE I KNOW MY CUSTOMER.
FIVE SECONDS.
SO, UM, I ALSO LIKE
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR FAMILY
BEHIND YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
TIME IS UP.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
STEPHEN HAS AN OFFER
ON THE TABLE FROM DAMON --
$500,000 FOR 33% OF HIS FOLDABLE
LUGGAGE COMPANY, BIAGGI.
BUT LORI MAY ALSO BE INTERESTED.
ALL RIGHT.
TIME IS UP.
LORI, ARE YOU GONNA
GIVE HIM AN OFFER OR NOT?
I AM GONNA GIVE HIM
AN OFFER.
HURRY UP!
O'Leary: TODAY?
SO, I'M GOING TO OFFER YOU
THE $500,000.
I ALSO WANT 33%.
YOU KNOW, I'VE ALREADY THOUGHT
OF A NEW NAME, PACKAGING.
THIS IS A REALLY TOUGH DECISION.
SHE'S ALREADY
CHANGING THE NAME.
SHE'S GIVING YOU
A JANET JACKSON DEAL.
Herjavec: HOW IS THAT
A JANET JACKSON DEAL?
Greiner: THAT'S CRAZY.
'CAUSE SHE WANTS CONTROL.
O'Leary:
THINK ABOUT THIS.
I'M NOT GOING TO INSULT HIM
BECAUSE I'M A GOOD PERSON.
O'Leary: YOU'VE GOT
TWO OFFERS -- TWO OFFERS!
IS IT OKAY IF I STEP OUT AND
MAKE A PHONE CALL ABOUT THIS?
STEPHEN, YOU'VE GOT
TWO SMOKING-HOT OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
YOU'RE GONNA LET YOURSELF
STEP OFF THE CARPET?
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN HAPPEN.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS PICK ONE.
John:
AND THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS,
I LIVE IN NEW YORK IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY LIKE YOU DO.
OOH.
SO WE CAN TALK OFTEN.
AND I'VE SEEN YOUR MAYBACH IN
THE PARKING LOT ON 33rd STREET.
THERE YOU GO.
LET THE GUY PICK.
I WORK AT LIGHTNING SPEED.
WE'LL HAVE THIS ON QVC
WITHIN FOUR MONTHS.
THANK YOU.
BE RIGHT BACK.
I HOPE NOTHING BAD HAPPENS.
BAD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
MAN: Hello?
HEY.
SO, I GOT TWO OFFERS,
ONE FROM DAMON JOHN AND THE
OTHER ONE IS FROM LORI GREINER.
Okay.
THEY BOTH HAVE ACCESS
TO ALL THE RETAILERS.
IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME OFFER.
THEY WANT TO GIVE $500,000
FOR 33%.
YOU KNOW, IT'S SO TOUGH.
Look.
All I can tell you is, you
have to gauge which one of them
is really going to be
most interested,
but beyond HSN and QVC.
Greiner:
I THINK HE'S GONNA PICK YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE FROM NEW YORK
AND HE WANTS YOUR MAYBACH.
WELL, I MEAN,
HOW MANY YEARS OF LUGGAGE
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING?
THAT'S ONE OF YOUR CATEGORIES?
I'VE BEEN DOING LUGGAGE
FOR AT LEAST THE LAST DECADE.
AND THAT'S A CATEGORY.
YOU ALREADY HAVE YOUR --
IT'S A STRONG CATEGORY
FOR ME.
I'VE SOLD HUNDREDS OF THOUS--
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS' WORTH.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT, STEPHEN.
LET'S RESET THE TABLE.
OKAY.
YOU HAVE TWO VERY VALID OFFERS
FROM TWO SHARKS,
EACH OFFERING YOU $500,000
FOR 33 1/3%.
THEY'RE IDENTICAL.
IT'S TURNED
INTO A BEAUTY CONTEST.
NOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
OKAY.
ONE SECOND.
I WANT TO MAKE
ONE STATEMENT.
I JUST NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS
YOUR NEXT PLAN OF ACTION?
STORES?
OR IS YOUR PLAN DEMONSTRABLE
ON THE QVC
OR HSNs OF THE WORLD?
DEMONSTRABLE,
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE.
LISTEN.
IN YOUR BEST INTEREST
TO GO DOWN THAT PATH,
EVEN THOUGH I WORK WITH HSN,
SHE HAS
AN EXISTING CUSTOMER BASE.
SHE WILL DO AMAZING THINGS
WITH IT.
I HATE
ACTUALLY SAYING THAT.
I'M GONNA STEP OUT.
WHOA!
[ SIGHS ]
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW WE KNOW
A LOT OF THE SAME PEOPLE,
I KNOW WE'VE WORKED BASICALLY
IN THE SAME BUILDING.
LORI, I -- I KNOW
YOU CAN KILL THIS ON QVC,
AND I'D BE HONORED
TO WORK WITH YOU.
WHOO-HOO! YAY.
O'Leary: OUTSTANDING.
Hersh: THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
GOOD JOB, STEPHEN.
Herjavec: GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S VERY CLEVER.
IT REALLY SOLVES A PROBLEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD. WELL, WELCOME
TO MY SHARK FAMILY.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
DAMON, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU OUT THERE.
John: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T WANT TO BE
MR. KNOW-IT-ALL
AND LET MY EGO GET IN THE WAY
WHEN THE BEST THING
FOR THAT ENTREPRENEUR --
LORI ALREADY HAS AN EXISTING
CUSTOMER THAT TRUSTS HER,
AND LORI WOULD BE BETTER
FOR HIM.
UGH!
THAT'S SO NASTY.
THAT TASTES SO NASTY.
WELL, THANK YOU, DAMON.
WHATEVER.
[ Chuckling ] OH!
Greiner:
WE'RE AT BED BATH & BEYOND TODAY
TO SEE MY SPECIAL
"SHARK TANK" SECTION
THAT WILL BE FEATURED
AT SELECT STORES NATIONWIDE.
THIS SPECIAL SECTION FEATURES
SIX PRODUCTS I'VE INVESTED IN
FROM "SHARK TANK,"
AND I'VE BROUGHT THEM ALL DOWN
HERE TODAY
TO SEE IT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
JOINING ME ARE SCRUB DADDY,
DROP STOP,
READEREST, SCREENMEND,
INVISIPLUG, AND FiberFix.
THIS DISPLAY
IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL THING
I HAVE EVER SEEN.
AND I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT
'CAUSE IT'S OUR PRODUCT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY
MIND-BLOWING.
EVERYTHING THAT LORI
TOUCHES IS COLD.
AND BEING ON HER DISPLAY
IS JUST AN UNBELIEVABLY
EXCITING EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS SUCH A BIG DEAL
FOR ALL OF US.
THESE ENTREPRENEURS ARE REALLY
PERFORMING FANTASTICALLY.
THEY'VE DONE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN SALES,
$62 MILLION COLLECTIVELY.
BEFORE GOING ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE'D ONLY DONE
ABOUT $4,000 IN SALES.
SINCE WE AIRED ON "SHARK TANK"
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO,
WE'VE DONE
OVER $1 MILLION IN SALES.
Man: THE KIND OF GROWTH WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST YEAR
IS REALLY UNHEARD OF.
WE'VE DONE $10 MILLION
IN SALES.
IN ONLY 9 MONTHS,
WE'VE GROSSED $800,000.
IN LESS THAN 3 YEARS, WE JUST
HIT $10 MILLION IN SALES.
Man #2: SINCE WE DEBUTED
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO,
WE HAVE GROSSED
OVER $10 MILLION IN SALES.
Bilello: SINCE DOING A DEAL WITH
LORI ONLY TWO SHORT YEARS AGO,
WE'RE ABOUT TO REACH
$30 MILLION.
"SHARK TANK" IS NOT A SHOW.
IT'S A PHENOMENON.
LET'S GO CELEBRATE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I'M THRILLED TO HAVE YOU AS PART
OF MY "SHARK TANK" FAMILY.
IT'S A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME THING
TO PUT A DEAL TOGETHER
LIKE THIS.
IT JUST MEANS SO MUCH TO ME
BECAUSE THEY CHOSE ME
AS THEIR SHARK.
AND I REALLY THINK
THE SKY'S THE LIMIT.
All: THANK YOU, LORI!
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR WITH AN
INNOVATION IN MEN'S GROOMING.
HI. MY NAME IS LYDIA EVANS
FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS.
I'M SEEKING $125,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY,
SOAPS WASHES
& GROOMING ESSENTIALS,
BETTER KNOWN BY THE FELLAS
AS S.W.A.G. ESSENTIALS.
AS A LICENSED ESTHETICIAN
WITH EIGHT YEARS IN DERMATOLOGY,
I HAVE ALWAYS HAD A PASSION
FOR SKINCARE.
ONE DAY, MY BROTHER, A BARBER
OF 15 YEARS, CALLED,
BEGGING ME TO MAKE A PRODUCT
FOR HIS CLIENTS
THAT SUFFER FROM RAZOR BURN
AND HAIR BUMPS,
ALSO KNOWN AS FOLLICULITIS.
FOLLICULITIS IS WHEN THE HAIR
GETS TRAPPED
BENEATH THE HAIR FOLLICLE,
BEGINS TO BREED BACTERIA...
EW.
...AND CAUSES THE SKIN
TO BECOME ITCHY AND IRRITATED.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY NASTY STUFF.
SO, I STARTED JOTTING DOWN
FORMULATIONS, AND VOILà,
THE S.W.A.G. BAR WAS BORN.
THE S.W.A.G. BARS WENT ON SALE,
AND IT WAS ON.
NOW WHEN THE GUYS
SEE ME AROUND TOWN,
ALL I HEAR IS, "HEY, SOAP LADY!
YOU GOT THE GOODS WITH YOU?"
"WELL, OF COURSE, I DO.
MEET ME AROUND BACK."
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE S.W.A.G. BAR
HAS A THREE-IN-ONE VERSATILITY
THAT ALLOWS A GUY TO CLEANSE,
EXFOLIATE, AND DISINFECT
THE SURFACE OF HIS SKIN
IN ONE EASY USE.
WITH YOUR HELP, THIS BAR
IS GONNA TAKE OFF LIKE A G5.
WHO'S GONNA FLY AIR S.W.A.G.
WITH ME?
BECAUSE TOGETHER,
WE'RE GONNA CLEAN UP.
I HAVE SOME SAMPLES FOR YOU.
BRING ON THE S.W.A.G.
THANK YOU, LYDIA.
YES, SIR.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, LYDIA.
OH, YES, MR. WONDERFUL.
HELLO, DAMON.
THANK YOU.
HOW YOU DOING?
NICE TO MEET YOU.
NICE MEETING YOU.
THANK YOU, LYDIA.
THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
I AM FORMULATING ONE
WITHOUT LOOFAH.
SO, THE LOOFAH'S IN HERE?
THE LOOFAH'S IN THERE.
WHAT'S LOOFAH?
IT'S A FORM OF SPONGE,
RIGHT?
IT'S CATEGORIZED AS A SPONGE.
O'Leary:
IT'S ACTUALLY A PLANT
FIRST USED BY THE ANCIENT ROMANS
IN THEIR BATHS...
OH, MY GOD.
YES.
...TO EXFOLIATE.
LYDIA?
YES?
I'M NOT 1,000 YEARS OLD
LIKE KEVIN.
YES.
SO, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT LOOFAH IS.
BUT WHAT ELSE IS IN HERE?
'CAUSE I SEE ALL KINDS
OF THINGS IN THE SOAP.
THERE'S -- WELL,
IT'S A PROPRIETARY PRODUCT,
SO I CAN'T DISCLOSE THAT TO YOU.
YOU TOOK THE LOOFAH
AND POURED THAT IN?
HAVE YOU PATENTED THAT?
I HAVE NOT PATENTED.
AND LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU
WHY I HAVE NOT PATENTED.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO RELEASE
MY INGREDIENTS.
IT'S 63 DIFFERENT INGREDIENTS
THAT GO INTO THAT BAR.
63 THINGS IN HERE?
YES, SIR.
63 INGREDIENTS.
AND IT'S ALL NATURAL.
DO YOU HAVE
ANY SALES, LYDIA?
YES, SIR.
WE'RE LOOKING AT $54,500.
AND HOW HAVE YOU
SOLD THAT?
THROUGH MY BROTHER'S
BARBERSHOP AND THE WEBSITE.
HOW MUCH ON THE WEB?
HOW MUCH IN THE BARBER SHOP?
I WOULD SAY 75% WEB,
25% BARBERSHOP.
AND DO YOU MAKE THIS
FOR WOMEN?
I AM LOOKING INTO THAT BECAUSE
A LOT OF GUYS ARE SAYING
THAT THEIR GIRLFRIENDS
ARE USING IT
ON THEIR LEGS AND BIKINI AREAS,
AND IT'S REAL POPULAR
FOR THAT.
WELL --
LYDIA, WHAT DO YOU
SELL IT FOR?
YOU KNOW --
THOSE RETAIL FOR $15, SIR.
AND I HAVE A 75% MARGIN.
YOWZA.
WOW.
SHE'S TALKING DIRTY NOW.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU MAKE IT FOR?
I MAKE IT FOR $3.07.
THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WOW. ARE YOU
MAKING THIS YOURSELF?
YES, MA'AM, I AM.
I MAKE IT FROM MY HOME.
OH, YOU MAKE IT
IN YOUR HOME?
FROM YOUR HOME?
YES, SIR, I DO.
O'Leary: LYDIA, WHAT HAPPENS
IF YOU GET FUNDED
BY ONE
OF THE SHARKS TODAY?
YOU'RE MAKING THIS
ON YOUR KITCHEN TABLE.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA SCALE
THIS BUSINESS
SO THAT YOU HAVE WORLD
DOMINATION OF LOOFAH SOAP?
THAT'S THE PLAN,
WORLD DOMINATION.
I'VE ALREADY RESEARCHED
EVERYTHING THAT I KNOW
THAT I NEED
TO GET INTO A WAREHOUSE
AND PRODUCE ON A LARGER LEVEL.
WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU NEED?
LARGER EQUIPMENT.
RIGHT NOW, I'M DOING 20 GALLONS.
YOU CAN GET MELTERS FOR SOAP
UP TO 150 GALLONS.
John: THAT SOUNDS
TIME CONSUMING.
YES.
IS THIS YOUR ONLY JOB
AT THE MOMENT?
I'M AN ESTHETICIAN BY TRADE.
NOW, WHAT DOES YOUR HUS--
ARE YOU MARRIED?
I -- MNH-MNH.
NO, SIR.
OH.
WHOA, DAMON.
YOU KNOW SOME SINGLE GUYS?
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
OH, YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
DON'T LOOK AT ME.
NO, SIR.
I'M NOT MARRIED.
NO CHILDREN.
SO, THIS IS MY BABY.
IT'S MY BOYFRIEND, IT'S MY BEST
FRIEND, IT'S MY ROOMMATE.
Herjavec: LYDIA?
YES?
I KNOW WHAT I KNOW,
AND I KNOW WHAT I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT THE RIGHT PARTNER
FOR YOU.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT A LOOFAH WAS.
I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
THIS IS A VERY AWESOME PRODUCT.
VERY INNOVATIVE.
IT WILL BE THE VERY FIRST ONE
IN THE WORLD
TO COME TO THE MARKET
THE WAY IT IS.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT. I THINK
IT'S A VERY INNOVATIVE IDEA,
BUT REALLY A HOBBY AT THIS POINT
ON YOUR KITCHEN TABLE.
IF YOU ALREADY SET UP
MANUFACTURING,
YOU WERE TRYING TO POUR GASOLINE
ON THAT TO ACCELERATE IT,
THAT WOULD BE
MORE INTERESTING.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF HURDLES
YOU'RE GONNA FACE.
IT'S TOO EARLY FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, I LOVE INNOVATION.
YOU TOOK TWO THINGS,
YOU PUT IT TOGETHER,
AND YOU'VE CREATED
A BETTER MOUSETRAP.
THANK YOU.
PROBLEM FOR ME IS,
IT'S ONE SKEW THAT ISN'T
TESTED OR PROVEN YET.
I'M OUT.
LYDIA, WHY HAVEN'T YOU
TAKEN IT
BEYOND YOUR BROTHER'S
BARBERSHOP IN HOUSTON?
UM, IT HAS GOTTEN
OUTSIDE OF HOUSTON
BECAUSE I HAVE PEOPLE
FROM MY WEBSITE.
WELL, ONLINE, RIGHT.
I GET THAT FROM ONLINE, RIGHT?
YES.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD
JUST SEEM TO ME
THAT IT WOULD BE COMMON SENSE
TO SAY, "LOOK.
WHERE'S THE CLOSEST
BARBERSHOP?"
AND THEN JUST DRIVE THERE
AND SAY, "LOOK.
"IT WORKED
AT MY BROTHER'S SHOP.
WHY DON'T YOU GIVE IT
A TRY?"
BUT THAT'S WHAT I NEED YOU FOR.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
LYDIA?
I'M NOT HERE TO GO DOOR TO DOOR
TO EVERY BARBERSHOP.
NO, I'LL GET THE WORK DONE.
MY RISK/REWARD FOR THE AMOUNT
OF WORK IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO JUST GET YOU TO WHERE
YOU NEED TO BE TO SCALE...
MM-HMM.
...IT'S NOT WORTH MY TIME.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
DAMON?
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
John: MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE PRODUCT BEING GREAT,
YOU'RE GREAT.
OH, THANK YOU.
YOUR DECISIONS IN LIFE
WERE WHAT GOT YOU HERE,
WHICH IS GREAT.
BUT YOU'RE SMARTER THAN ME
IN THIS AREA.
SO, WE NEED EACH OTHER.
IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING TO ME, DAMON?
NO, I WOULD BE OF LITTLE --
I WOULD BE OF LITTLE SERVICE
TO YOU IN THIS AREA.
I DON'T THINK THAT
I'M TOO SHABBY FOR A YEAR IN.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T SEE ANYTHING
IN A YEAR IN.
IT HAS CAUGHT FIRE.
I WOULD NOT BE
OF HELP TO YOU.
WITH THAT BEING SAID...
...I'M OUT.
BUT I AM GONNA GIVE YOU
MY NUMBER.
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHEN I WILL BE SINGLE.
[ Chuckling ] OH, MY GOD.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I LIKE LONG ROMANTIC WALKS
TO THE BANK.
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE.
[ LAUGHS ]
GREAT JOB, LYDIA.
YOU JUST GOT TO GET
TO THE NEXT STEP.
DO I HAVE TO TURN AROUND
AND WALK OUT?
YES, YOU DO.
O'Leary: YEAH.
WAY TOO EARLY.
Greiner: WAY TOO EARLY.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO COME IN
AND DO ALL OF HER ACCOUNTING.
BUT IT'S A VERY SMART IDEA.
Evans: THEY LOVED MY PRODUCT,
AND THAT WAS EXCITING.
THAT'S REALLY
ALL THAT MATTERS TO ME.
DAMON, CALL ME!
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A COUPLE
WITH A FASHIONABLE ALTERNATIVE
FOR COLLEGE SPORTS FANS.
HI.
I'M SHAWNNA.
AND I'M KURT.
WE'RE FROM OKLAHOMA,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS GAMEDAY COUTURE.
WE ARE SEEKING $500,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
SO, NOW,
WE ALL KNOW SPORTS FANS
ARE EXTREMELY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THEIR TEAMS, RIGHT?
SO, WE USED TO GET READY
TO GO TO THE BIG GAME.
AND I LOOK OVER AT THIS GUY,
AND HE WAS DECKED OUT
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
BUT I GO TO MY CLOSET,
AND I WAS LEFT
WITH EITHER
AN OVER-SIZED JERSEY
OR A LIGHT PINK T-SHIRT.
I THOUGHT, "REALLY?
COME ON.
WE CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT."
AND GAMEDAY COUTURE
WAS BORN.
[ WHISTLE BLOWS ]
WE TAKE WHAT'S TRENDING
IN THE FASHION WORLD
AND BRING IT TO THE FEMALE
SPORTS FAN MARKET.
HIGH-QUALITY FABRICS
AT COMPETITIVE PRICE POINTS.
AND GAMEDAY GIVES WOMEN
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK COMFORTABLE
YET STYLISH
OR DECKED OUT
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
SO, WE'RE A SUCCESS
IN THE SOUTH,
BUT WE WANT TO DRESS FANS
FROM ALL OVER.
WHO WANTS
TO JOIN TEAM GAMEDAY
AND MAKE A STATEMENT
WITH FAN FASHION?
OUR MODELS ARE GONNA
PASS OUT SOME SAMPLES
FOR YOU GUYS RIGHT NOW.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
IT'S ALL FOR FEMALES,
OBVIOUSLY, RIGHT?
CURRENTLY, YES.
WE FOCUS ON THE FEMALE MARKET.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES SO FAR?
WE DID ABOUT $750,000
IN SALES LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR,
WE'VE DONE ABOUT $1 MILLION.
WE'RE ON PACE
TO BE ABOUT $1.5 MILLION.
Herjavec: GREAT GROWTH.
IMPRESSIVE.
SO, I DID AN INVESTMENT
LAST SEASON, UH, TIP SALES.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THEY MAKE
THE UGLY CHRISTMAS SWEATERS.
WE'RE KILLING IT.
WE'LL DO $4 MILLION THIS YEAR.
RIGHT.
WE'RE NOW EXPANDING
INTO THE COLLEGE MARKET.
Kurt: MM-HMM.
OKAY.
AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS,
IT'S VERY, VERY EXPENSIVE
TO BUY THE LICENSES
FROM EACH COLLEGE.
EXPENSIVE.
YEAH.
Herjavec: HOW MANY
COLLEGES, UNIVERSITIES
DO YOU HAVE LICENSES FOR
ACROSS THE STATES?
AS WE STAND RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE ABOUT 37 LICENSES.
WE'VE GOT A FEW MORE
ON THE WAY.
O'Leary: TELL ME
THE AVERAGE PRICE POINT.
AVERAGE PRICE POINT'S $22,
WHOLESALE.
AVERAGE RETAIL'S $44.
WHAT DOES IT COST FOR YOU
TO MAKE IT?
ABOUT $8.
Greiner: RECENTLY, I WENT
TO A BLACKHAWKS GAME.
MY HUSBAND SAID, "YOU KNOW,
"IT'D BE GREAT
IF WE WORE SOMETHING,
THE COLORS, ET CETERA."
WE'RE ONLINE.
WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALL THE DIFFERENT SHIRTS.
I DIDN'T LIKE ANYTHING
UNTIL I CAME TO ONE
THAT WAS LIKE YOURS...
MM-HMM.
...THAT WAS BLINGY.
SO, THAT'S WHAT I BOUGHT.
MY POINT IS THAT
YOUR PRICE POINT'S GOOD.
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT MINE
COST LIKE $60-SOME-ODD.
AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
WE REALLY WORKED HARD
WITH A LOT OF OUR RETAILERS
AND THE UNIVERSITIES
DIRECTLY TO DEVELOP --
WHAT WE ARE KNOWN FOR
IS AN ALUMNI CUT
AT A COMPETITIVE
PRICE POINT.
HOW MUCH MONEY
WILL YOU MAKE THIS YEAR?
ABOUT $100,000
OUT OF $1.5 MILLION.
OKAY.
SO, IT'S NOT A LOT.
WHY ARE YOU WORTH $2.5 MILLION?
WE'RE WORTH $2.5 MILLION
BECAUSE WE HAVE PUT
ALL THE MONEY BACK IN
TO APPLYING
THE ADDITIONAL LICENSES,
SEEKING OUT THE MARKETS.
SO, LAST YEAR,
WHEN WE DID $750,000,
THAT WAS BASICALLY SHIPPED
ON JUST 10 SCHOOLS.
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO, LIKE, RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE ABOUT 37 SCHOOLS.
OKAY. I GET THAT.
Herjavec: WOW.
SO, YOU'VE BUILT A PLATFORM
UPON WHICH ONE DAY, WITH
SUCCESS, YOU'LL MAKE MONEY.
RIGHT.
BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S WORTH $2.5 MILLION.
THE LICENSES ARE VALUABLE.
YOU'VE GOT THEM.
THAT'S CORRECT.
RELATIONSHIPS ARE VALUABLE.
YOU'VE GOT THEM.
THAT'S CORRECT.
THEN I ASK MYSELF,
"WHAT WOULD IT COST ME
TO GO CATCH UP WITH YOU?"
THERE'S NOTHING STOPPING ME
IF I WANTED TO GET
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
I'M THINKING PROBABLY
IF I FUNDED $750,000,
I'D GET A TEAM LIKE YOU
AND I JUST RUN LIKE HELL
AND GET THOSE LICENSES, TOO.
YOU COULD GO OUT AND SPEND
A BUNCH OF MONEY ON IT,
BUT WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO?
I'VE ALREADY JUMPED
OVER ALL THE HURDLES,
AND I'M STILL SPRINTING.
WELL, I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT --
YOU DON'T MAKE ANY MONEY,
SO I --
WE'VE ALREADY DONE
ALL THE HARD WORK.
YOU DON'T MAKE ANY CASH FLOW.
I UNDERSTAND.
THE KEY TO BUSINESS
IS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE RIGHT PRICE
TO BUY IN IS.
SURE. SURE.
BECAUSE IF YOU OVERPAY,
YOU DIE OF OLD AGE
BEFORE YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
I THINK YOU OVER-PRICED
YOUR BUSINESS.
I THINK YOU'RE WORTH
ABOUT $750,000.
I'D HAVE TO OWN, YOU KNOW,
75% OF YOU AT THIS PRICE.
I'M OUT.
AND I'LL LET SOMEONE ELSE
TRY AND FIGURE IT OUT.
SO, THE NBA CALLED ME,
AND THEY SAID, "HEY.
"WE WANT TO GIVE YOU A LICENSE
BECAUSE WE WANT YOU
TO MAKE FASHIONABLE STUFF
FOR ON-COURT AND OFF-COURT."
SO, I MADE THESE GREAT KNICKS
AND BULLS VELOUR SUITS.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IS,
THE KID JUST WANTED
THE $40 JERSEY WITH
HIS FAVORITE PLAYER ON IT.
THAT'S ALL HE WANTED.
SO, I ENDED UP HAVING
ABOUT $10 MILLION
IN INVENTORY THAT...
[ WHISTLES ]
...WAS PRETTY CHALLENGING.
I'M STILL LICKING
MY WOUNDS A LITTLE.
SORRY. I-I'M OUT.
THIS WOULD BE A REALLY GREAT
PIECE FOR YOUR PORTFOLIO.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK DOWN THAT ROAD AGAIN.
YOU DON'T WANT
TO GO OUT ON THIS.
I'M STILL NOT THROUGH
MY CURRENT INVENTORY.
DAMON, I SEE
SOME GROVELING GOING ON.
CAN YOU TELL THEM
WHAT IT'S WORTH?
$1.5 MILLION.
HE'S VERY GENEROUS.
YOU'RE ONLY $1 MILLION
OVER VALUED.
THAT MEANS ROBERT CAN STEP UP
AND MAYBE DO SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW, IT'S $500,000.
RIGHT?
IT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
NO, IT'S NOT.
SO, VALUATION MATTERS, ROB?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
PLEASE.
DON'T YOU HAVE THE VISION?
BUT EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING
IS EXACTLY WHAT I WOULD HAVE
TOLD YOU TO DO.
SURE.
I WOULD SIMPLY RUN
A LITTLE BIT FASTER.
YOU KNOW, DAMON THINKS
IT'S WORTH $1.5 MILLION.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I SAW IT BEING WORTH
AROUND $1 MILLION...
OKAY.
Herjavec: ...FOR THE RISK.
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL TO YOU.
YOU'RE NOT DISRESPECTFUL.
IT'S UNDERSTANDING
KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT
WITHIN OUR INDUSTRY.
IT IS WORTH A WHOLE LOT MORE
THAN WE'VE EVEN PROBABLY
GIVEN IT CREDIT FOR.
OF COURSE IT IS.
BECAUSE WE'VE SCRATCHED
THE SURFACE.
YOU KNOW, SHAWNNA,
FOR ME, TODAY,
IT'S WORTH
THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT...
TOTALLY.
I RESPECT THAT.
...AS AN INVESTOR.
AND YOU'RE NOT
GONNA TAKE THAT.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LORI OR MARK,
ANY OF YOU GUYS INTERESTED?
WHAT -- WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
DOING ONLINE?
WE JUST LAUNCHED ONLINE
LAST YEAR, RETAIL,
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO FOCUS ON
OUR WHOLESALE BASE
AND GET THAT BUILT FIRST
BEFORE WE JUST BRANCHED
INTO TOO MANY THINGS.
BUT, GUYS, MOST OF YOUR BUSINESS
SHOULD BE ONLINE, RIGHT?
'CAUSE I WOULD THINK ANY ALUM,
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
THEY'RE GONNA GET TO YOU.
CORRECT.
AND MOST OF OUR RETAILERS
SELL ONLINE.
AND THERE'S
A HUGE OPPORTUNITY.
LOOK. I'M KIND OF SURPRISED
YOU DIDN'T GO THAT WAY SOONER
BECAUSE IT'S MORE OF A PATH
OF LEAST RESISTANCE.
SURE. SURE.
RIGHT?
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
I'M MISSING
IN TERMS OF WHY
YOU DIDN'T GO ONLINE?
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, WHEN
WE GO OBTAIN THESE LICENSES,
WE WORK WITH THESE
LICENSING DIRECTORS.
AND THEY WANT TO SEE US DO
SOMETHING WITH THE LICENSE.
IS THERE A LIMIT?
ARE YOU NOT ALLOWED
TO SELL ONLINE WITH YOUR --?
NO, YOU ARE. WE ARE.
YEAH, WE ARE. WE ARE.
BUT THEY REALLY WANT
TO SEE YOU TAKE THE LICENSE
AND DO SOMETHING WITH IT
WITHIN THE FIRST --
John: OKAY.
ONE SECOND.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SHOW
A LICENSING ORGANIZATION
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
ON THE INTERNET SAYING,
"I'M INTERESTED."
THAT'S EXACTLY CORRECT.
BUT IT IS REALLY EASY TO SHOW
THEM ORDERS FROM 50 STORES
SAYING,
"THIS IS AN OFFICIAL ORDER."
DID THAT HAPPEN?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
OKAY.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
OKAY?
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU THE 500K.
OKAY.
FOR 30%.
OKAY?
BUT I HAVE A CAVEAT.
BUT I'M NOT GONNA TELL YOU
WHAT THE CAVEAT IS,
WHAT THE CONTINGENCY IS,
UNTIL YOU GIVE ME AN ANSWER.
SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TRUST ME
A LITTLE BIT.
I MEAN, YOU'VE GOT TO TELL ME --
ABSOLUTELY.
I DEFINITELY WANT TO --
I WANT TO RESPECT YOUR OFFER.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T LEAVE
ANYBODY OUT, LIKE LORI.
I'M NOT GONNA GO THERE, GUYS.
IF I'M NOT THE RIGHT PARTNER
FOR YOU, JUST TELL ME.
NO, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU ARE THE RIGHT PARTNER
FOR US.
A BIRD IN THE HAND.
YOU JUST GOT TO TELL ME
WHETHER WE HAVE A DEAL.
OKAY.
LET'S DO IT.
NOW I'M GONNA TELL YOU
MY CONDITION.
OH.
Greiner: YEAH.
OKAY.
MY WIFE KILLS ME
EVERY SINGLE YEAR
SAYING THE MAVS HAVE
HORRIBLE CLOTHING FOR WOMEN.
I'VE ALREADY GOT A DESIGN.
DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
Herjavec: WOW.
Cuban: IF I DIDN'T DO
A DEAL WITH YOU GUYS,
MY WIFE WOULD HAVE SHOT ME.
SHE WOULD.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE --
IT'S GONNA BE AWESOME.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH.
THANKS, GUYS.
Kurt: SUPER FIRED UP
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH MARK.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT DOESN'T TAKE NO
FOR AN ANSWER.
AND HE'S GONNA BE ABLE
TO GET US OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE.
Greiner:
IT WILL SELL GREAT.
John: BLING FOR WOMEN
IS LIKE THE LIGHT
THAT THE MOTH
KEEPS GOING TOWARD.
AND I WANT ONE.
DONE. AS LONG AS
IT SAYS MAVS ON IT.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS
AN ENTREPRENEUR WHO BELIEVES
HE HAS A BETTER SOLUTION
TO DRINKING WINE ON THE GO.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S ANDREW McMURRAY,
AND I'M HERE
FROM SCARSDALE, NEW YORK.
OUR COMPANY
IS ZIPZ INCORPORATED.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING
A $2.5 MILLION INVESTMENT
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
OH.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT OUR SINGLE-SERVE
IS LIKE NO OTHER
IN THE WINE INDUSTRY.
OUR COMPANY, IT'S ALL ABOUT
PACKAGING, PACKAGING, PACKAGING,
AND LICENSING,
LICENSING, LICENSING.
AND, KEVIN, I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE MUSIC TO YOUR EARS.
YOU ARE WISE, GRASSHOPPER.
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, THE SINGLE SERVES THAT
ARE OUT IN THE MARKET TODAY,
WHAT YOU MIGHT BE MOST USED TO
THAT YOU SEE ON AIRPLANES,
THE LITTLE AIRPLANE BOTTLES,
LITTLE PLASTIC CUPS.
WE'VE GOT A WINE GLASS.
IT'S GOT WEIGHT,
AND IT'S GOT STRENGTH.
AND THIS GLASS IS ACTUALLY SO
STRONG THAT I CAN STAND ON IT.
Greiner: OH, MY GOD.
Herjavec: WOW.
WOW.
Greiner: WOW.
"WOW" IS RIGHT.
TO OPEN THIS GLASS OF WINE,
YOU'RE SIMPLY GONNA UNZIP
THE OUTER CLING WRAP.
THIS RECYCLABLE OUTER WRAP
ACTS AS A U.V. PROTECTANT
TO THE WINE,
WHICH IN SINGLE-SERVE WINE,
SHELF LIFE IS KING.
NOW, TO OPEN THE WINE, YOU'RE
SIMPLY GONNA UNSCREW THE LID...
Herjavec: OH.
...ATTACH IT TO THE BOTTOM.
OH!
VERY CLEVER.
THAT'S GREAT.
NOW, TO OPEN THE WINE,
YOU'RE SIMPLY GONNA LIFT
AND PEEL.
ONE OF THE BEST PARTS
ABOUT THIS NOW,
LID COMES BACK OFF,
SCREWS BACK ON.
THIS GLASS FALLS OVER, YOU'RE
NOT SPILLING ANY WINE OUT OF IT.
SO, LET ME QUICKLY GIVE YOU GUYS
EACH A GLASS SO YOU CAN HOLD IT.
IN OUR OPINION,
OUR PACKAGE IS GONNA BECOME
TO THE WINE INDUSTRY
WHAT THE ALUMINUM CAN BECAME
TO THE SODA INDUSTRY.
Greiner: CHEERS.
CHEERS.
O'Leary: SO, FOR VIEWERS
OUT THERE AND YOU, LORI,
WHO WEREN'T AROUND
WHEN THIS HAPPENED,
COPA DI VINO WAS ANOTHER
SINGLE-SERVE WINE DEAL
THAT CAME IN THE TANK TWICE.
BOTH TIMES, GOT OFFERS, AND HE
NEVER ACCEPTED EITHER OF THEM.
Herjavec: ANDREW, WHY IS IT
DIFFERENT THAN COPA DI VINO?
IT'S DIFFERENT IN THAT
WE OWN THE PATENTS AND --
O'Leary:
COPA DI VINO ASSURED US
THEY HAD A PATENT ON SEALING
A GLASS OF WINE THIS WAY.
SO --
SO, HOW HAVE YOU NOT
BREACHED THAT PATENT?
ACTUALLY, THE COMPANY THAT OWNS
THE RIGHTS TO THAT GLASS
AND TO THAT TECHNOLOGY IS
A COMPANY BASED OUT OF FRANCE.
IN SPEAKING WITH THE OWNER
OF THE COMPANY,
HE TOLD US THAT
THE PREVIOUS ENTREPRENEUR,
ESSENTIALLY, HE'S A --
LIKE A FRANCHISEE.
SO, HE HAD THE RIGHTS TO USE
HIS TECHNOLOGY FOR HIS GLASS.
SO, WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOUR TWO PATENTS?
THE SHELF LIFE.
THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO.
OUR GLASS LASTS FOR WELL
OVER A YEAR, SHELF LIFE.
WE'RE IN SHELF-LIFE TESTING
RIGHT NOW WITH THREE
OF THE TOP 10 GLOBAL BRANDS
IN THE WORLD TODAY.
ONE I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT,
WHICH IS YELLOWTAIL.
THEY DO CLOSE TO 10 MILLION
CASES A YEAR IN THE U.S. MARKET.
SO, WHAT I'M TRYING
TO CLARIFY WITH CERTAINTY --
BECAUSE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD
A LONG TIME AGO.
AND, BY THE WAY, YOU'RE DOING
BETTER THAN THE OTHER GUY
'CAUSE HE WAS SWEATING LIKE
A PIG BY THIS POINT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THE POINT IS,
YOU'RE TELLING ME,
AFTER HAVING VISITED
THE OWNER OF THE PATENT,
THAT THERE IS NO BREACH?
THEY HAVE AGREED THAT YOU DO
NOT INFRINGE ON THEIR PATENT?
THAT IS 100% CORRECT.
IS YOUR PATENT UNIQUE
NOT ONLY TO THE FORM FACTOR
BUT ALSO TO COAT THE GLASS
WITH THAT PLASTIC?
CORRECT.
THE MIX OF THE PLASTIC THAT'S
IN HERE IS PROPRIETARY TO US.
THAT'S WHAT --
ALONG WITH
THE EXTERIOR PACKAGE?
ALONG WITH THE EXTERIOR PACKAGE.
SO THOSE TWO THINGS --
THAT'S ALSO A PART OF THE PATENT
IS THE U.V. WRAP,
THE SHRINK WRAP ON THE OUTSIDE.
SO, THOSE TWO THINGS --
OKAY.
OKAY, LET'S PUT THE PATENT ASIDE
FOR A MOMENT.
OKAY. SURE.
YOU HAVE NO DESIRE
TO MAKE YOUR OWN WINE.
YOU WANT TO LICENSE
THIS PACKAGING
TO OTHER BIG WINE MANUFACTURERS
AND LET THEM SELL IT?
THE ANSWER WOULD BE NO AND YES
AND YES AND NO.
SO, WE ACTUALLY HAVE
OUR ZIPZ BRAND.
THAT'S WHAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS OUR BRAND.
IS IT IN COSTCO?
IT IS NOT IN COSTCO YET.
Greiner: WHAT --
AND THAT'S A BIG PIECE OF WHY
I'M HERE TALKING TO YOU TODAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
OKAY. THE PROJECT STARTED
ABOUT 16 MONTHS AGO.
WE ARE WORKING
WITH FETZER WINERY.
THE DEAL WITH THEM WAS
TO GET INTO SIX
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL PARKS
FOR OPENING DAY OF 2013.
AND WE DID $130,000 WITH THEM
IN LICENSING FEES.
THEY TOOK YOUR TECHNOLOGY
AND PUT THEIR WINE INTO IT
AND SENT IT OVER
TO THE ARENAS?
CORRECT.
IS THAT THE LICENSE?
WHAT WAS THE PERCENTAGE
ON THAT LICENSE?
IT'S 15 CENTS A GLASS.
HOW MUCH MONEY
IS TOTALLY INVESTED
IN THIS VENTURE RIGHT NOW?
$8.5 MILLION.
OH.
Herjavec: WOW.
WOW.
AND WHERE DID THAT MONEY
COME FROM?
McMurray: WE GOT ABOUT
25 INVESTORS, TOTAL.
WE'VE GOT SIX RETIRED
GOLDMAN SACHS PARTNERS,
THREE OF WHICH OWN A
PROFESSIONAL SPORTING FRANCHISE.
AND THE REST OF THIS GROUP,
THESE ARE ALL
WALL STREET PROFESSIONALS.
John:
BUT THE QUESTION BECOMES,
IF YOU HAVE
ALL THOSE TEAM OWNERS,
THEN WHY ARE YOU ASKING US
FOR THE MONEY?
I WANT ALL FIVE OF YOU GUYS
AT THE TABLE WITH ME.
WHAT'S IT SELL FOR?
WHAT'S YOUR TOTAL SALES?
THE ZIPZ BRAND THAT YOU'RE
HOLDING IN YOUR GLASS RIGHT NOW,
WE'VE CURRENTLY DONE
ABOUT $650,000 IN SALES.
WHAT DOES IT COST AT RETAIL,
A GLASS OF ZIPZ?
$2.99 PER GLASS.
O'Leary: LOOK.
VERY FEW PEOPLE WILL BUY
A GLASS OF WINE FOR 3 BUCKS.
WE'RE ALREADY IN 1,200 STORES.
WE JUST GOT WALMART THIS WEEK.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
IT COSTS ME 95 CENTS.
OOH. LOOK.
IN AMERICA, 97% OF WINE
IS SOLD FOR UNDER
$9.95 A BOTTLE.
SO, WHERE THIS PACKAGING IDEA
HAS SO MUCH MERIT
IN TERMS OF ITS DELIVERY,
IT FAILS ON ITS PRICING.
WHEN THE AVERAGE CONSUMER
SAYS TO HIMSELF,
"I CAN GET 5 1/2 GLASSES
FOR $9.99,
AND I HAVE TO PAY $3.99
FOR ONE,"
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YEAH, BUT THIS IS, YOU KNOW --
BUT THE -- YOU CAN'T DISMISS --
LIKE YOU SAID,
YOU CAN'T DISMISS THE PACKAGE.
BUT YOU'VE ONLY GOT $650,000
IN SALES, MY FRIEND.
THAT'S NOTHING
IN THE WINE BUSINESS.
I MEAN, EVERYONE WE'VE SPOKEN TO
IS COMFORTABLE
AT THE $2.99 PRICE POINT.
THEY HAVEN'T SOLD
THROUGH ANY.
THAT'S THE TIPPING POINT.
LIKE YOU SAID --
THEY HAVEN'T
TESTED THE MARKET.
THEY HAVEN'T SOLD IT THROUGH.
$650,000 IN 1,200 STORES
IS POO-POO.
POO-POO.
PEE-PEE, POO-POO.
BUT LET'S NOT GET HUNG UP
ON THOSE. NOW WE --
I'M HUNG UP.
I KNOW IT'S GETTING DE-LISTED.
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
NO. BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MY BRAND.
LOOK.
I'M NOT A WINE CONNOISSEUR.
BUT EVEN THEN,
I WOULD TAKE MD 20/20
FROM A QUALITY PERSPECTIVE
OVER A BRAND WITH
A ZIPPER NAMED ZIPZ.
HUGE MISTAKE.
I'M OUT.
LET ME TELL YOU
A VERY BRIEF STORY
THAT I THINK
WILL BE SOBERING FOR YOU.
I WENT TO SEE COSTCO
AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT WINE.
THEY'RE THE LARGEST BUYER
OF WINE ON EARTH.
SURE.
$5.2 BILLION IN WINE.
I SAID, "I'M GOING
INTO THE WINE BUSINESS."
THEY SAID, "WHO CARES?"
THERE'S 5,000 APPLICATIONS
A YEAR
TO PUT WINE FROM ALL AROUND
THE WORLD INTO COSTCO.
"GO PROVE THAT O'LEARY MEANS
SOMETHING IN THE WINE BUSINESS."
IT TOOK ME TWO YEARS TO DO IT.
I GO BACK TO COSTCO.
AND SHE SAYS, "IMPRESSIVE.
BUT NOW YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH A NEW PRICE POINT."
WE TALKED ABOUT SINGLE SERVE.
WE TALKED ABOUT
750 MILLILITER BOTTLES.
WE TALKED ABOUT MY BRAND.
DID YOU GET YOUR WINE
INTO COSTCO?
I'M NEGOTIATING IT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NOT IN YET.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
John: THAT WOULD BE
A NO. OKAY.
WHAT IS YOUR LOSS
GONNA BE THIS YEAR?
WE -- I DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT IT
AS A LOSS.
I WANT TO LOOK AT IT
AS A REINVESTMENT BACK.
WHY NOT SIMPLY LICENSE
TO THE BIG MANUFACTURERS,
TO THE BIG WINERIES,
AND LET THEM TAKE ALL OF THAT?
YOU'RE PUTTING UP
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF CAPITAL.
THAT'S NOT THE PURPOSE
OF A LICENSING DEAL.
WHY DO ANY OF IT?
WELL, I MEAN,
HINDSIGHT IS ALWAYS 20/20.
THAT'S THE ANSWER?
Cuban: NOW HE'S IN.
NO!
NOW HE'S TOO FAR IN.
HE'S GOT NO CHOICE.
OKAY. SO, AT THE PRICE OF $2.99
THAT YOU WANT TO SELL IT AT,
IF YOU DON'T GET
THE SELL-THROUGH
UP TO, CALL IT, 10 MILLION UNITS
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS,
YOU'RE SCREWED.
YOU'VE RUN OUT OF RUNWAY.
SO, THE REAL ISSUE
IS GETTING BACK
TO HOW WE STARTED
OUR CONVERSATION TODAY,
WHEN WE KNOW EVERYBODY
IN AMERICA, WHICH IS 97%,
BUY WINE AT UNDER $9.99.
THAT'S 97% OF THE MARKET.
AND WHERE'S THAT FACT FROM?
I --
EVERYTHING I'M TELLING YOU
IS A FACT.
YOU'RE GONNA GO FIND THIS OUT
ON YOUR OWN.
John: MY GUT FEELING IS,
I WOULD NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
INVESTING THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY
WITH THIS AMOUNT OF RISK.
I'M OUT.
OBVIOUSLY, I RESPECT THAT
AND I APPRECIATE IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
TO OPEN A CATEGORY
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
ISN'T EASY.
IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE.
THE GUY'S BEEN STANDING THERE.
TWICE.
HE WAS HERE TWICE!
TO CLEAR THE AIR IN THAT SENSE,
I MEAN, WE'RE NOT A COPY CAT.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINGLE-SERVE WINE SINCE 2008.
YOU KNOW, I THINK
BRILLIANT DESIGN.
I LOVE IT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, I THINK
THAT THERE'S A GREAT USE FOR IT
IN CERTAIN APPLICATIONS.
BUT ALL THE REST OF THIS
IS SO COMPLICATED --
YOU HAVE SO MANY PARTNERS,
IT'S SO MUCH MONEY --
THAT FOR THAT REASON, I CAN'T
SEE MY WAY THROUGH THIS.
AND SO, I'M OUT.
Herjavec: YOU KNOW, WHEN
COPA DI VINO WAS HERE,
I REALLY LIKED
THE PRODUCT THEN.
I LIKE THE BETTER PRODUCT,
'CAUSE I THINK
YOU HAVE A BETTER PRODUCT.
BUT MY ISSUE IS EXACTLY
THE SAME AS IT WAS.
I DON'T CARE THAT
YOU'VE RAISED $8.5 MILLION.
FOR ME, IT IS VERY,
VERY FUNDAMENTAL.
IT'S A LICENSING DEAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE HAVING THIS DISCUSSION.
KEVIN'S GONNA BEAT
THE CRAP OUT OF YOU
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET BELOW
A CERTAIN PRICE POINT.
BUT YOU CAN'T GET BELOW
A CERTAIN PRICE POINT
BECAUSE YOU'VE TAKEN ON
ALL THE RISK.
IF YOU WERE
SIMPLY LICENSING IT,
THAT WOULD BE
SOMEBODY ELSE'S PROBLEM.
I DON'T LIKE THE PATH
THAT YOU'RE GOING DOWN.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT, LOOK.
COSTCO IS
THE NUMBER-ONE BUYER
AND RE-SELLER OF WINE
ON EARTH, PERIOD.
EVERYTHING ABOUT
SELLING WINE IN AMERICA
IS KNOWN
BY THEIR BUYING TEAM.
WHICH BRANDS?
WHICH VARIETALS?
WHAT PRICE POINT?
WHAT PACKAGING? EVERYTHING.
THEY KNOW EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
THEY DON'T LIKE
THIS PRICE.
IF I TEAM UP WITH YOU,
I CAN GET THIS INTO COSTCO.
BUT NOT AT THAT PRICE.
YOU WANT TO DO $12 MILLION
OPENING ORDER
FROM CALIFORNIA ALONE?
IT'S $1.49.
YOU WANT TO DO A $19 MILLION
A YEAR BUSINESS WITH COSTCO?
IT'S $1.49.
I CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN.
I CAN GET YOU IN COSTCO.
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN IS ANDREW'S LAST CHANCE
FOR A DEAL
FOR HIS SINGLE-SERVE
WINE COMPANY, ZIPZ.
O'Leary: SO, HOW DO YOU GET
THE PRICE DOWN
SO THAT WE CAN SELL
TO COSTCO FOR $1.06?
HOW DO WE DO THAT?
YOU'VE GOT TO GET
THE PACKAGING DOWN.
AND, LIKE ANYTHING,
WHEN IT GOES TO SCALE,
WE FEEL WE CAN KEEP
DRIVING IT DOWN.
ALL RIGHT.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
HERE'S THE ONLY WAY
I'M DOING YOUR DEAL.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN GOING DOWN
THE PATH YOU'RE GOING DOWN,
TRYING TO PROVE OUT
A $2.99 PRODUCT
'CAUSE I KNOW
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
I'M TWO YEARS AHEAD
OF YOU, OKAY?
I WANT TO GO LAUNCH IT
IN COSTCO.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF THE OFFER
OF GETTING INTO COSTCO?
ABSOLUTELY.
John: OKAY.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I'LL GIVE YOU
$2.5 MILLION FOR 10%.
BUT I WANT THE OPTION
TO BUY ANOTHER $2.5 MILLION
WORTH OF EQUITY
AT EXACTLY
A $25 MILLION VALUATION
IN THE EVENT OF AN EXIT.
WHICH MEANS IF YOU SELL
THE COMPANY FOR $50 MILLION,
I STILL GET TO BUY IN
AT $25 MILLION.
YOU GET IT?
I'VE GOT TO HAVE SOME UPSIDE
FOR MAKING YOUR COMPANY SO
VALUABLE THAT YOU CAN SELL IT.
AND OF COURSE,
ALL OF THIS ONLY HAPPENS
IF WE GET INTO COSTCO.
SO, YOU HAVE NOTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND IT?
YES, I DO.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A QUICK PHONE CALL...
YES.
...TO CHECK WITH THE INVESTORS.
ALL RIGHT.
[ SIGHS ] THESE WINE GUYS
DRIVE ME CRAZY.
I THINK THEY'RE NUTS
NOT TO DO YOUR DEAL.
IT'S JUST A POTENTIAL DEAL
WITH KEVIN.
SCOTT: Kevin only?
KEVIN ONLY.
Okay.
FOR 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN THE COMPANY.
AND HERE'S THE TWIST
AND THE KICKER.
SO, OBVIOUSLY,
WE NEED TO DISCUSS THIS.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS YOUR WAY
OF YOU GETTING IN TO COSTCO?
YEAH.
AND THAT'S WHY
YOU WANT TO DO IT.
Herjavec: YEAH, BUT THIS
IS THE BEST OFFER
KEVIN'S EVER MADE
TO SOMEBODY.
OKAY. SO, IN SPEAKING TO THE
PARTNERS, THEY WERE INTRIGUED.
IT WASN'T THE ANGLE THEY THOUGHT
THAT YOU WOULD BE COMING IN AT.
I DESERVE TO BUY STOCK
AT A $25 MILLION VALUATION,
ANDREW,
BECAUSE I BROUGHT COSTCO
TO THE TABLE.
BECAUSE WE GOT INTO COSTCO,
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU'RE WAY MORE VALUABLE.
YOUR PARTNERS KNOW THAT.
YOU SHOULD DO THIS DEAL.
YOU HAVE NO RISK.
JUST SAY YES.
[ CHUCKLES ]
TRUST ME.
ANDREW, IT'S ACTUALLY
A VERY GOOD DEAL.
ANDREW, ARE YOU GONNA
TAKE MY DEAL OR NOT?
DON'T BE A FOOL.
I'M ON BOARD.
YAY!
ALL RIGHT.
CHEERS.
YAY! [ LAUGHS ]
Greiner: YAY!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRAB YOUR VERY EXPENSIVE
PLASTIC GLASS AND TOAST ME.
CHEERS.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WHOO!
[ SIGHS ]
HERE'S TO THAT BEING OVER.
Herjavec: CHEERS.
CHEERS.
McMurray: GOING IN TO THIS,
WE KNEW THAT KEVIN
WAS THE WINE GUY.
TO HAVE KEVIN O'LEARY,
MR. WONDERFUL,
PART OF OUR WINE PROJECT THAT
WE'RE DOING -- PRETTY EXCITED.